if anyone is on the field and is
disrespectful to the anthem of the flag
there would be a fine from the league
against the team the NFL without the
Players Union has decided to attack the
the lack of standing before the national
anthem we've listened to a lot of
different viewpoints including our fans
over the last year and I think this
policy attempts to to come out in a
place where we respected everybody's
point of view in this all 32 clubs want
to make sure that during the moment of
the anthem and the flag that that is a
very important moment to all of us as a
league as clubs personally and to our
country you have to stand proudly for
the national anthem
well you shouldn't be playing you
shouldn't be there maybe you shouldn't
be in the country you have to stand
proudly for the national anthem there's
been incredible engagement with the
players on this we've talked to tens if
not hundreds of players about this over
the last year or so to get their input
to understand their positions all
players were on the field when the
national anthem plays must stand or face
fines Mike Pence celebrated the
spontaneous tweet hashtag winning well
maybe not so fast Mike Pence
[Music]